tough cookie stop calling the symptoms
of more than half the population
atypical last week not only did I give
you two videos that were quite deep in
terms of their topics but they were
quite long as well so I appreciate you
watching them and leaving your feedback
in today's video I'd like to address
some of the most common critiques and
criticisms from those videos in addition
to responding to comments as I usually
do let's get started
stop calling the symptoms of more than
half the population atypical I got this
comment a lot and I totally understand
why the tricky part about recognizing
heart attack symptoms in female patients
is that they are often masks and they
often present atypically
it sounds like I'm calling the symptoms
of a heart attack
atypical because they happen in the
female population that's not the case
the majority of all people men and women
experience heart attacks with chest pain
now if you're having jaw pain stomach
pain nausea fatigue and you're having a
heart attack that is an atypical
presentation whether you're a male or
female what I was trying to say in the
video is that if you're a woman you're
more likely to have these atypical
symptoms not that all women experience
atypical symptoms and men experience
classical symptoms that's not how that
works mellow 24 in New Jersey you
mentioned women use a more narrative
style of talking and that makes doctors
have more errors isn't that a form of
victim blaming Bella I can see how you
can get there what I think the study was
trying to accomplish was to figure out
reasons why women were being
misdiagnosed when it comes to the way
they present their illnesses now this is
not saying that it's the woman's fault
for having this narrative style this
study is identifying that this is the
cause and then we can further address it
by educating doctors to be better suited
to accept this type of presentation some
advice that I give to all my patients
irrespective of their sex is that they
should not be afraid to be outspoken if
a doctor is doing something that they're
not comfortable with or if they feel
that doctor is missing something they
should speak up if that doctor is not
willing to listen and communicate get a
second opinion that's not always
feasible in a given moment but it's
important to advocate for your own
health this is not to excuse bad doctors
habits this is simply a practical
solution for a problem that I see a
purring quite often Jon's llama I hear
you but to be perfectly honest you sound
like you are justifying and making
excuses I understand your medical
provider but please try and see this
from a patient's perspective it would be
more helpful
John's Ilana I'm sorry you feel that way
I really do and try and see all of these
situations from a patient's perspective
not only have I been a patient but my
family have been patients I lost my mom
to cancer and I spent a lot of time in
hospital so I do know how the system
works intimately from a professional
perspective and a patient's perspective
that being said the purpose of me doing
the reaction video to this was not to
defend doctors it was simply to take a
360 look at the issue and really point
out that while bias and discrimination
definitely occur we need to talk about
it I also didn't want to lose focus and
see that there's a lot of other issues
that are contributing to these
disparities that weren't discussed on
this bit je delat n I liked Heights book
but I can't help but see a bit of
contradiction here because he says kids
are anti fragile so don't over protect
them but yeah he wants them to be kept
away from social media altogether
Jonathan Hyde made a really good point
that we had to edit out simply for time
sake because this was a hundred-plus
minute interview and we did only show
you 48 minutes so I'll let him say his
take but I have a slightly different
opinion on the matter
okay height you're saying that we need
to let kids out more and not supervise
them and kids have to climb trees and if
you get injured but then you're saying
we shouldn't let them on social media
aren't you coddling them and over
protect them for social media and I say
well yeah you know logic that's a good
point but let's see if it's the same
kind of learning you know when you climb
a tree and you get in trouble you get
scared or you or you fall over hurt
yourself you learn you don't avoid trees
you actually climb trees better the next
time but when you're shamed on social
media what happens I always ask to say
everybody's in Gen Z how many of you
have been on it since you were 10 or 11
years old a lot of hands go I say okay
do you think that being on social media
early and being shamed and being
attacked do you think that overall
that's made you tougher and more
independent because I've been shamed in
fact so many times I don't care or do
you think it's made you more hesitant
it's made you more self censoring it's
made you more careful of what you say
and the overwhelming consensus it's a
large majority say it's the former that
they don't know the latter the large
majority say that it's that they're more
they're more they're more self censoring
basically more cowardly in my opinion we
don't want to expose children to
unnecessary chronic stress or chronic
trauma and I think social media falls
into that category if my child goes to
school and gets called a name and comes
home upset about it that's good that's
an acute stress they're gonna learn how
to deal with that but now if they're
being called that name every single day
at school being bullied then they come
home and they're being bullied on social
media that never stops that now crosses
the line into chronic stress / trauma
where I need to step in my second point
of social media is that really functions
like a drug because of the way that it
affects our minds the likes create a
dopamine hit much like vape pens do
cigarette smoking alcohol use does and
we don't let young children use those
because they haven't quite developed a
frontal cortex the decision-making part
of their brain so exposing them to
social media earlier on can really
affect the way they mature and their
circuits form so I think keeping
children away from social media until
they're mature and that line is
different for everybody it's not a bad
idea this is the first time I've turned
off one of your videos the implication
that children shouldn't be protected
from bullying or emotional abuse as
ridiculous it doesn't make children
stronger but it does make many of them
suicidal including me now Sarah I'm
incredibly sad to hear that and I'm
sorry you had that experience watching
our video the type of conversation that
Jonathan Hyde and I are having is really
fraught with nuance because it's really
important that we don't just say oh all
children should be bullied and they'll
become stronger and that's all good
that's not what we're saying and it's
really important that we pay attention
to that bit of nuance what we're saying
is that acute stress small amounts of
struggle challenges are good for
children well we don't want to see
happen as children exposed to serious
traumatic events chronic abuse or
bullying because in that case it changes
from a healthy challenge to an unhealthy
challenge now that line is different for
every child based on how they've
developed maturity based on what
experiences they've had in their lives
based on their parents even and that's
really up to the parents of
side where that line lies both too much
and too little intervention can have
adverse effects Faro Mike I am a real
doctor also Mike I don't know my blood
type oh my god there were so many
comments about this it is perfectly
normal to not know your blood type for
example if I have a patient come into
the office and I order them a complete
blood count a complete metabolic panel
vitamin test cholesterol panel thyroid
panel whatever it is it doesn't
automatically come in to tell me their
blood type that's a special test that I
have to order and guess what your
insurance is going to say well why did
you need to know that why are we paying
for it if it's not of medical necessity
you have to pay for the one time that
your insurance will pay for it that will
apply to a lot of people is in a
preoperative setting so if you come to
me and you're about to go to for surgery
you need clearance I'm the one that's
going to be doing that clearance I may
order a blood test just to make sure
that if something happens during the
operation we have your blood type ready
to go and save your life
panda read my health economy teacher
told me to always be positive but never
HIV positive if you're HIV positive
that's okay too we can figure it out in
fact the control for HIV has gotten so
good at the life expectancy for someone
who takes treatment carefully and
properly and appropriately for HIV is
essentially the same life expectancy as
for the average person of that same sex
and age Kim carpenter I have epilepsy
and I was wondering what goes on in my
brain whilst that happens Kim that's a
really great question now I'm not a
neurologist but I'll sort of give you a
very basic explanation of what happens
in one part of your brain there happens
to be an area of over excitation almost
like an electric storm and then that
starts spreading throughout your entire
brain that's how you can develop
epilepsy and go into a full-on seizure
where you're shaking you're feeling
things seeing things are confused
because it activates all different parts
of your brain interestingly enough if
patients fail medical therapy meaning
taking all these types of medications
for their seizures one of the possible
treatments is surgical intervention
literally taking out the part of the
brain where we've isolated the beginning
of that seizure activity to that pin
part of the brain Regan RN dr. Mike
where is the difference between an MD
and a do and which is better you phrased
your question in the exact title that I
have a video already-existing and that
video just hit a million views I'm gonna
link it down below in the description
it's called what is the difference
between an MD and a do and which is
better I'm very passionate about this
subject I'm actually partnered with the
American Osteopathic Association which
represents well over a hundred thousand
practicing dioz and we're gonna be
giving all sorts of little tidbits about
the differences and what makes a deal
special so stay tuned for that
Carolyn vice video idea can you do a
video about surgery anxiety what to
expect I'm having surgery for the first
time and I'm really nervous Caroline
this is such a good idea
part of my job as a family medicine
doctors to do pre-surgical clearances
which means that right before a patient
gets to go under the knife they come to
me first to make sure that they're
healthy enough to go for surgery or at
least optimized well enough to go for
surgery during this process I have
really in-depth conversations about
their fears about what they need to be
doing beforehand and I think that could
make for a really good quality video I
know what questions most people have and
I know what language I need to use to
explain that to them if you want that
type of video someone's got to be the
leader here and put a really good
comment down below this video and upload
that bad boy let's make the limit for it
5,000 up boats if you get that dedicated
video to pre-surgical anxiety a deep all
question what happens if you stay
upside-down for an extremely long time
you're gonna get a headache because
gravity's gonna change the amount of
blood that's going to your head you're
gonna get a lot more blood pooling there
now your legs are used to this because
obviously you're standing it upright for
the majority of the day in fact the
veins in your legs have natural valves
that has each time your heart pumps
those valves open and then closed to
make sure that the blood doesn't
automatically fall and pull to the
bottom of your legs you may see this and
some people as they get older when those
valves become incompetent or they have
damage to their veins and you see that
their legs are constantly swollen all
day that's because blood is pooling down
there and their venous system is a
little bit abnormal luck so health
question why can't I see when I close my
eyes
because you have eyelids if they're not
transparent there's actually some
animals I know that have transparent
eyelids and in a regular eyelids they
can see underwater if you know what kind
of animal that is drop it down below in
the comments because I need a refresher
I think it's a toad or snake Oh
alligators whatever Jennifer Saunders
this man really just pulled out nuts out
of his dishwasher put them in the king
class there are way too many jokes to be
made about that entire situation man
like I was so tired of delirious when I
was filming that yes I store my nuts in
my dishwasher and I put them in the
drinking glass deal with it Jocelyn Raj
dr. Mike I love nuts fans start mailing
all kind of nuts to him actually if you
want to send me some interesting nuts
I'm down I've got to be careful when I
say things like that I feel like I'm
gonna go to my P o box and be
unpleasantly surprised what's in the box
I know many of you were scared off by
the 48 minute mark on my latest anxiety
video but I urge you make the time check
out this video leave me your comments
because I'm still very active in that
comment section and as always stay happy
and healthy
[Music]